alien covenant promise to explore the
mysterious and goopy lineage of the
xenomorph species that we all know and
love birth in many cases it just left
the entire alien franchise open to even
more questions
let's burrow into covenant steak our
ovipositor x' down its throat and to see
how many answers are still waiting to
hatch and of course spoilers are
hatching beyond this point so cover your
face okay who are the engineers more
than anything else covenant needed to
explain just what the heck it's prequel
Prometheus was all about from easier
introduced us to the engineers an alien
race who inexplicably started life on
Earth we don't know exactly why and
that's what the crew of the Prometheus
sets out to discover what we hope to
achieve was to meet our makers to get
answers where they even here from the
first pavilion however once the Android
David actually finds the engineers and
all of the answers are within reach he
slimes them an entire city of engineers
is destroyed by David stock of evil
black goo we never learn who the
engineers are why they do what they do
or where they came from and thanks to
David we may never know why did David
kill the engineers the motivations of
the covenants human crew are pretty
straightforward just don't die however
the Alien franchise is Android tend to
be a little harder to read and a none
are more confusing than David if it
comes clear in both Prometheus and the
introductions the covenants that David
sees himself as superior to humans and
even expresses the bizarre idea that all
creations want to kill their creators
Calhoun much care are you sure you might
be mad at mom for not letting you borrow
the car on a school night
but that's pretty much the extent of
matricidal rage that most people reach
so why exactly does David wipe out the
engineers it's possible that mankind's
implied creators david is just taking
his murder plot one step deeper into his
ancestry but there isn't a whole lot of
meaning there and he definitely doesn't
do it to protect Earth from the
engineers so what's the deal what did
the goo do when we meet David again in
covenant he leaves the crew into the
derelict city of the engineers through
masses off their dead bodies of course
they're all dead thanks to David's give
but what exactly did this do do as far
as anyone can tell it mutates any living
animal that comes into contact with but
we never find out what it did to the
engineers
if the goo did what you usually does the
entire engineer planets would be
swarming with xenomorph so where did all
those potential xenomorphs end up after
10 years what happened in the five
minutes after the goo drop
why was the engineers planet lifeless
the planet that the Covenant lands on is
ideal for life but inexplicably the crew
can't seem to find any no birds no bugs
just silence as David tells his guests
the virus he dispersed was made to seek
out hosts so all of the meat from the
planets became an immediate target as
soon as he dropped his payload but none
of the morphs that would have resulted
from his attack seemed to still be
around
nothing is ultimately trying to
comprehend what goo Canon cannot do is
the job of best left for Ridley Scott's
pulsating nightmares but that mysterious
decade where David was left to his own
messed up devices leads to many
mysteries for the continuity concern so
now let's just say it was predators
what's up with those spores the crew of
the Covenant gets their first taste of
alien madness when a couple of dinguses
brush against some plants suck in some
alien dust and after a little while have
monsters birthing out of their giblets
it's basic science except human DNA and
engineered DNA are allegedly nearly
identical it wouldn't make much
biological sense if the engineered
planet was right with a violent strain
of murder monster mushrooms so these
balls of alien death confetti must not
have always been there instead they must
have been caused by David's use of the
go the goo can mutate every animal that
comes in contact with so why did it very
selectively choose one plant to turn
into a vehicle for the species arguably
it's not a plant at all that shoots out
those spores but that still leaves
questions but these pods parts of
David's later experiments and if so why
are facehuggers treated as a superior
form of alien evolution the spores
method of propagating the species is
only a million times more efficient than
the alien
egg pods the choice is simple your
species propagates because an idiot
actively agitates a giant ugly egg and
waits for its terrifying contents to
attack and shove an egg tube down their
throat or your species lives on because
something gently brushes against a small
pod with their so the more efficient
method is clear so what makes the eggs
more evolutionary sound than the spores
is David de xenomorph or Whisperer it's
easy to argue that aliens aren't overly
interested in androids because they
don't really have a lot of delicious
edible parts so if you're a synthetic
being you pretty much get a xenomorph
full pass but while the Zeno Moore's
David is cultivating strangely loyal to
him at the very least they seem to see
him as one of the only living things
that's not worth immediately killing
which is really saying something when
you're an animal designed only for
killing we know xenomorph stones
imprints on the first thing they see
like many earth animals so how does
David automatically have this dominion
over the beasts maybe we'll learn the
answer in a sequel and the while we're
on the subject of synthetics is Walter
still alive alien is a franchise that
relishes showing the audience every gory
detail of nearly every bloody death so
when someone dies and you don't at least
see their viscera strewn corpse
you know something might be up during
the first phase of the big fight between
David and Walter we see that Walter has
the ability to heal himself while he
takes a few minutes to reboot it seems
like he can recover from some pretty
deep cuts now stand aside worthy
adversary tis but a scratch a scratch
the arms off no I didn't after the
second phase of their big battle we
learn that David comes out on top and
switches places with Walter we never
learn Walter's fate but when even an
earlier Android model like David can
survive decapitation we can assume that
Volterra still alive or can we don't
know dude everyone knows that you can't
keep a good droid down thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your loved thing
[Music]